AliveCor got started because of the invention
of a really brilliant doctor, Dr. Dave Albert.
His latest invention was a small device that is about the size of a stick of gum.
And this extraordinary device works with
your smartphone and allows you to analyze the EKG of your heart,
not a heart rate, not like you might get with a Fitbit or with a sports watch.
But the actual electrical rhythm of your heart which
is incredibly important to diagnose some of the more serious heart conditions.
Most people don't realize that heart disease is
the number one killer of men and women worldwide.
In fact, last year about 18 million people died from heart disease.
What's next for AliveCor is probably the most exciting part.
We are working on some extraordinary technologies using deep learning,
artificial intelligence that analyze the morphology of your personal EKG,
your heart, and detect things that previously were not available to human eyes.
The machines can see things about your health that were previously
undiscovered whether that be potassium levels or other measures of physiology.
We're just getting started on unlocking the secrets of your heart.